hunger and fear are excellent causes
hope is brightest when it Dawns from
fears
war is the only game in which both sides
lose
we are like the herb which flourisheth
most
and trampled upon
Revenge
the sweetest morsel to the mouth that
ever was cooked in hell
a sound head an honest heart
and a humble Spirit are the three best
Guides Through Time and to Eternity
those who are not afraid of death are
capable of anything
it happens that a bad tree produces good
fruit
and bad times give rise to more than
just evil
moments of grave danger often coincide
with moments of heartfelt frankness
all men who have turned out worth
anything
have had the chief hand in their own
education
there is no better antidote against
entertaining too high in opinion of
others
than having an excellent one of
ourselves at the very same time
a true Knight is a lamb in the company
of ladies
and a lion during a fight
he that climbs a ladder must begin at
the first round
gold killed more souls than iron killed
bodies
no word of commiseration can make a
burden feel one feather's weight lighter
to the slave who must carry it
judgment is always done very quickly if
the judge decides beforehand
the closer to the church
the father from The Lord God
we sculpt our Idols out of snow and cry
when they melt
Crystal and hearts would lose all their
Merit in the world if it were not for
their fragility
he is not fit to visit strange countries
who cannot rule his tongue before his
own countrymen
don't be wasteful
and you won't need much
a Fool's wild speech confounds the wise
when we remember friends who are no
longer alive
we feel doubly alone
Simplicity may be improved
but pride and conceit never
the spectacle of Victory is even more
terrible than the spectacle of battle
without courage there cannot be truth
and without truth there can be no other
virtue
the willow which bends to The Tempest
often escapes better than the oak which
resists it
oh what a tangled web we weave
when first we practice to deceive
recollect that the almighty who gave the
dog to be companion of our pleasures and
our toils
hath invested him with the nature Noble
and incapable of Deceit
need teaches everything
need is the mother of Courage
we shall never learn to feel and respect
our real calling and Destiny unless we
have taught ourselves
to consider everything as moonshine
compared with the education of the heart
subtle politics often puts on the guise
of the greatest innocence
just as sometimes real courage is hidden
under the most modest appearance
ignorance
ignorance and Superstition are the only
true misfortunes
a rich man may have his quirks because
he has the money to pay for them
of all the vices
drunkenness is more incompatible with
the greatness of the spirit than others
love will subsist on wonderfully little
hope but not altogether without it
success or failure in business is caused
more by the mental attitude even than by
mental capacities
the trouble with those who write quickly
is that they cannot write concisely
praise be to the Lord God who gave us
the ability to laugh and make others
laugh and shame on a fool who despises
the title of jester
tears are the softening showers which
cause the seed of Heaven to spring up in
the human heart
if people do not learn to help each
other
then the human race will disappear from
the face of the Earth
blessed be his name who hath appointed
the quiet night to follow the busy day
and the calm sleep to refresh the
wearied limbs and to compose the
troubled spirit
even a king in all the Splendor of his
power and Glory
if he is blinded by ignorance and
superstition
is less free than a sage who is Chained
in heavy chains and thrown into prison
come he slow or come he fast
it is but death that comes at last
Authority comes from Reason Not reason
from Authority
any Authority that is not recognized by
reason is powerless
one or two of these scoundrel Statesmen
should be shot once a year
just to keep the others on their good
behavior
[Music]
the solidarity of people
is an indestructible Fortress
look back
and smile at The Perils of the past
people often blame fate for what is a
direct consequence of their own violent
Passions
the lovers of the chase say that the
hair feels more Agony during the pursuit
of the greyhounds
than when she is struggling in their
fangs
the longer a person is single
the greater his desire to remain single
whoever realizes his innocence
he reluctantly Stoops two excuses
teach your children poetry it opens the
Mind lends Grace to wisdom and makes the
heroic virtues hereditary
always keep quiet about your problems
otherwise you will lose all your friends
trade has all the fascination of
gambling without its moral guilt
your soul is like a neglected Garden
belonging to a negligent owner
weeds have grown in it and drowned out
healthy sprouts
he that climbs the tall tree has one
right to the fruit
he that leaps the wide Gulf should
Prevail in his
discretion is the Perfection of reason
and a guide to us in all the duties of
life
love rules the court the the camp The
Grove
and Men below
and the Saints above
for Love Is Heaven
and Heaven is love
hourly can what we most despise in hate
approach in an outward manner
to that which we most venerate
as long as ambition and lust for power
rule the hearts of some men
there will be no lasting peace on Earth
War unfortunately
is The Human Condition
emotional agitation makes us forget
about caution
and we discover such feelings that in a
calmer time we would try to hide
if not able to completely suppress them
peace is an inestimable Jewel but it
will be soon snatched from those who are
not prepared with heart
and hand to defend it
teach self-denial and make its practice
pleasure
and you can create for the world a
destiny more Sublime than ever issued
from the brain of the wildest Dreamer
and that which is done of good will
must be accepted favorably
there are a few more Melancholy
Sensations than those with which we
regard scenes of past pleasure
when altered and deserted